and welcome to how to create a deck of
cards using object oriented programming
uh classes and
rendering through the class now this is
something i haven't done before
and i'm doing it kind of live here so
hopefully this will go well
one of my students is doing a similar
project and i wanted to see if i could
do it myself
so first quick shout out to my members
thank you so much for supporting the
channel directly
if you'd like to join click the join
button down below
so let's take a look at what we've got
nothing
okay so i what i want to do is i want to
create a deck of
playing cards so that's ace king queen
jack 10 down through two
and we have clubs let's see was it club
spades diamonds
and hearts so i want to do a couple
things like simulate
you know the cards themselves and i want
to be able to draw them on the screen
i'm going to be doing that i'm going to
be using the turtle module which i use a
lot so
i'm going to go ahead and import turtle
and for those of you who've been
following my channel for a while this
should be very familiar
and turtle.screen and
win.bg color i'll make the background
color black
doesn't have to be that i'll say
win.setup i'm going to make it 800
wide by 600 tall
and let's see here what else can i do
with the window
ah win.title and we'll put like a nice
title there
we'll say deck of cards simulator
by at tokyo tokyo edtech speaking of
tokyo i'm sitting in tokyo right now
it is very very dark outside and there
is a thunderstorm warning so if you hear
some thunder and lightning
don't be surprised so i'm going to
scroll down a bit here and
i'm going to put wind.mainloop to keep
my program
open i'm going to run it right now and
check and notice i'm using the genie
editor i highly recommend it and if i
run this
i've got two screens going and there is
my deck of cards simulator
so what i want to do is i want to be
able to put some cards here on the
screen
and again i haven't done this before so
we kind of making it up as i go along
but i have a pretty good idea of of how
to do what i want to do here
so what i want to do is i'm going to go
ahead and create
some classes now if you haven't done
classes before
check out my oop you know introduction
to object-oriented programming and
classes tutorial
uh i think it's worth worth your time so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
create a class for a cart
and in my constructor
i want to create the card and i'm going
to create it's
each card has a name and a
suit okay so
the name would be ace king queen jack
i'm going to use a key
a k q etc etc and suit is one of the
four
suits that i mentioned previously so i'm
going to say
self dot name equals name
and i'm gonna say self.suit equals
suit and what i'll do for suits i'll use
uh
d for diamond i'll use uh s for spade uh
what's the other ones i keep forgetting
c for clubs and
h for hearts now when we render it we're
going to render it a little bit
differently we're going to try and make
it look like the symbol
but for now we'll leave it like that
speaking of the symbol if you're not
familiar with
playing cards they look like this i
don't know about the pattern i don't
think i'm going to do that today
but i do want to get you know seven of
clubs seven of hearts etc etc
i won't be able to get it upside down
because i don't know how to do that with
the turtle module
but i do want to use these symbols so
let's uh yeah let's get back to the code
and now here's a question like at this
point
what what should i do first um do i want
to
deal with the deck and make 52 cards or
do i just want to make one
card and see if i can get it working and
basically what i usually do is i start
from the bottom up
so in this case i would just try and get
one card
working because once you have one card
working the rest of it's pretty
simple okay so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to create a pen
actually let's let's not do that part
first let's go ahead and just create a
card
so card very original equals
card now notice it says self now self
comes from here so card itself
and the name and suit so of course it's
going to come as no surprise
i'm going to do the ace of spades
okay so
what i can do
is i can make a function called print
card self and
let me keep this really simple so print
uh
self dot name self dot name
and self dot suit okay
and so then what i'll do is i'll create
a card and i'll say card
dot print or i could call it card.print
i guess but also called print card
and let's see what happens let's run it
okay so now the window's still coming up
but because i'm
printing okay it's coming up here so a
ace of spades
okay so i'm pretty happy with that so
far so good
now what i could do
is something like this instead is maybe
let's do let's do an f string
and put some parentheses here
or not parentheses but braces i don't
know if you can hear the wind picking up
outside it's getting pretty loud so i
apologize for that
and let's hopefully the electric doesn't
go out that's pretty rare here but it
does happen
let's go ahead and run that okay so that
is the ace of spades
but what i want to do is i want to
actually have those symbols
and as you saw earlier i already had the
wikipedia article
open so i'm going to go back here and
i'm going to go ahead and copy these
symbols
out of here so i'm going to cop watch
copy this whole thing and then delete
what i don't need
and come back to that and so what i'm
going to do
so i'm going to say symbol i don't know
simple i don't want to call it
equals that so if self.suit
equals well here's one thing i could do
self.suit equals
s which is for spades now it's a symbol
equals and i'll use the
spade symbol
okay so i'm just going to comment this
out for now i'm just going to test that
to see if it works
and we're going to run it and that did
not work because i want to now print
not the suit but i want to print the
symbol
okay let's close that and try it again
okay so you can see now i've got ace of
spades here
so i'm pretty happy with what's going on
so far
so thinking about this
now i could do four if statements
because there's there's only four
but probably what you want to start
doing is stuff like this
so symbols equals and we could use a
little dictionary
oops and oops comma
i'm doing a lot of java lately so i've
been throwing a lot of semicolons in
where they don't belong
and so we have four of these
and there we go so we're gonna do
uh what's we got uh diamonds
uh clubs
and note i could use these symbols but i
want to kind of keep it so that i can
type stuff in if i
if i need to and spades and then
i'm going to copy the symbols
and hearts
i don't know and i know my keyboard is a
little loud as well
i got to get a new one but uh i'm kind
of waiting
till chrono's over i think
yeah hopefully which will hopefully be
soon so
what i can do now
is i can do something like this uh
symbols and then i can just do like this
i can do
self dot uh suit
okay now i'm going to test that and see
what happens
i'm just going to close the old one
first and we still get ace of spades so
i'm pretty happy with that now i should
test it
and make sure it works but what i want
to do here
is i want to go ahead and start
rendering
and how i'm going to do that you know as
i mentioned earlier
i'm using the turtle module so
if i'm using the turtle module i need to
have something to draw with
so i'm going to go ahead and create a
pen now i don't have to call it pen but
that makes sense because i'm drawing so
pen equals turtle.turtle
again if you've seen my tutorials before
you know this is kind of how i do things
so i'm going to say pen dot speed equals
which i've sent that speed
0 that's the animation speed and i'm
going to say pen
dot hide turtle
because i don't need to see the pen i
just need to see what the pen can
draw so i'm going to go ahead and i'm
going to make
a new method and i'm going to call this
render let's call it render i guess self
and x comma y
oops so
using the pen
so here's what i'm going to do
i'm going to say pen dot go to i'll say
well i'll say pen dot pen up just to
make sure
pen dot go to uh
x comma y and then what i'm going to do
is i want to choose a color
based on well actually that's how i will
do
the border first i'll say pen dot color
white
now think about what the card looks like
let's go back to
uh this so you see how the card is
taller than it is wide
so it's probably what about two-thirds
give or take
so i'm gonna kind of decide how big i
want the card to be
and then here we're going to be drawing
from the center
so if this is the center of the card i
want to go up to this corner and start
drawing
an outline okay there's a big big
lightning strike just out the window
here so we should hear that shortly
um so i'm gonna basically be drawing the
outline so let's go ahead and try that
um i'll get back to there it was
okay so i'm going to say pen dot go to
x let's say x minus 50
and then we'll say y
plus 75.
i'm going to say pen dot pen down
and i'll say pen dot go to oops
x plus 50
y plus 75. so i'm drawing
top left top right i'm going to go
bottom right bottom left
back up the top so pen dot go to
x plus 50. y
oh this should be minus uh no this is
this is correct minus 75.
pen dot go to x minus 50
y minus 75
and pen dot go to uh
let's see x minus 50 back to the top
y plus 75.
okay so i'm going to do is i'm going to
say card dot render
i'm going to put we're going to put it 0
0
and we're going to use the pen
let's see if that works oh my gosh it
looks really good actually that's
exactly what i wanted
size wise okay now what i'm going to do
is i'm going to go ahead and i'm going
to
comment this out just so you can see
what's going on
i'm going to bring this up oops it's way
too fast okay tell you what i'll do
is i'm gonna hit delay i'm gonna say
delay
equals uh input
so that'll let me you know delay it
you'll see in a second um
so i'm going to pull this up and then
down here that's wrong screen
hit enter and then no you can't see that
okay lovely
all right um duh
so i'm gonna go ahead and import time so
import
time so i can do time dot sleep so
time dot sleep uh three seconds that'll
just give me
three seconds to get the screen on here
we go and it's going to start drawing
so you saw it started here went here
went down here went over here went up
here
so it works i'm pretty happy with that
so
what i want to do then is
so i'm going to say here let's see draw
the border
first now i'm going to draw
say draw suit in the middle
okay so this is pretty simple so i'm
going to say
so i'm going to put pen dot pen up
so we don't draw any more lines i'm
going to say pen dot go to
go back to the center which is x comma y
i'm going to say pen dot write
that's me self dot suit
oh no no no that's not correct because i
need the symbol
okay so all right what i'm gonna do
is i'm gonna move this out of here
and put that up here
okay so let's see here
self i want to do it that way
i'll do that way for now i know it's not
super efficient but
we'll leave it like that so i'm going to
make it self.symbols
self.suit okay and then i'm going to
write
self.symbols
self.suit
uh this should be false and i'm going to
use a font
so font equals
um i'll use courier i like courier
carrier new let's try
32 i don't have to pick a number and
let's should go here normal
okay oops don't forget the last quote
and we're gonna need an ooh
there's another big lightning strike out
the side here okay so i'm gonna
try this and see what happens
okay so you can see it's a little bit
off okay so it's not quite
centered as i would have liked it to be
so i have to like kind of play around
the numbers a little bit it's also not
as big as i like let's make it 64 and
see what happens um
oh yeah that's that's more what we're
talking about okay so
you can see how it's not centered um
why is that
probably yeah i know why it's doing that
um
so i'll show you why it's doing that i'm
going to like unhide the turtle
and that'll you'll see why it does that
just so you know
so you see the turtle's here but for
whatever reason the text is printed up
here i don't know why it does that
uh maybe somebody does i just think it
has a way that something to do with the
way the rendering is done
let me change the 48 that was a little
big so what i'll do
is i'm going to go to x1 i'm just going
to play around the numbers a little bit
and since it's 48 let's try 24 and
uh 24. i don't know if that's enough but
let's see if it works
okay it's pretty close it's close to
being centered
so i think it's probably going to depend
on the font and the size of the font
there might be an easier better way to
do this i don't know what it is but i'm
going to go ahead and just kind of play
around
i want to come down a little bit a
little bit to the right so i'm going to
make that
let's see 18 and i'll make that 30.
you may have to have different numbers
depending on how your computer is set up
okay now that's
that's pretty well centered i'm happy
with that so i'm going to hide the
turtle again
well actually well it doesn't matter i'm
going to hide the turtle i don't need to
see that
okay so now i want to add
you know it's like you have here i want
to add the seven of
you know the ace of diamonds or ace of
spades here
and now those of you like music you know
why i chose the ace of spades
out of respect to to lemmy and motorhead
actually it was online next to lemmy one
time uh in bucharest
uh yeah he was just right there at the
airport
and uh i didn't have the courage to say
anything to him so
uh but i was really close to lemmy it
was pretty cool anyway um
let's see draw top left
[Music]
okay so let's say pen dot go to
again i just got to kind of play around
with the numbers a little bit so i'm
going to try 40
i don't know because it's 50 and
why it's plus 75 so i'll try plus 65.
so x minus 40. so it's the center
wherever we drew it at
and i'm going to go ahead and copy this
because because i like to tell my
students i'm kind of lazy
so um so i'm going to do the symbol
and the name so self.name
and this has got to be a lot smaller i'm
going to try 12.
and i want this to be lower so
i'll try 55 with this
you can see the process i'm just kind of
i don't know quite what i'm doing
i'm just kind of experimenting until i
get what i want
okay well it's not too bad so you can
see how it's just a little bit too high
so i think the size isn't too bad maybe
a little bigger let's make it
let's try 18. and again this will depend
on your fonts and
your computer a little bit and 65 so
let's make that
155 make this one
40. since i made the font a little
bigger
oh it's really close now okay so i'm
just going to move those down a bit
let's say 45 30.
yeah i can live with that not too bad so
there's our ace of spades
and i'm going to go ahead and i'm going
to put this in the bottom right
so i'm just going to copy this some kind
of like i said i'm kind of a lazy guy
i don't believe in repeating myself and
so
[Music]
so draw bottom right and i know it
should be upside down but i don't know
how to do that with the turtle module
so yeah anyway so this should be x
plus 40 so we're going to the right side
and try y minus
45 and y minus
30. let's see what happens now i think
it's going to flip them
but oh it's not even close to where i
wanted it
um yeah that's
yeah that's because the way the turtle
yeah it's weird but anyway
so we got to move it over to the left a
little bit so let's make that
30 and
let's try it again
so you see i'm just doing a little
experimentation now i don't like that
now normally this would be
reversed upside down but unfortunately
that's not going to be the case here
so let's flip this around
and you can see you know how there's
just this process
of kind of iteration i could prob and i
can't draw it out because i don't know
really
the right size i don't know how big
everything is and how the offsets work
on this
so yeah it's kind of annoying actually
but anyway
live and learn so we need them to go
down a little bit more
so let's say 45 and 60.
because i think there's 15 apart here
oh it's so close um so you see how
close that is i'm going to go ahead and
try 55
and 70.
okay i'm pretty happy with that okay so
we got the ace of spades
and now the other thing i would probably
want to do at this point
is actually what i'm going to do is i'm
going to change the background color
well let's see here
with the turtle module i know there's a
way to fill
in this background but i forget how to
do it
um
[Music]
okay well this is how we do figure these
things out let's go ahead and try it
so yeah you can see my old stuff i look
at in search
so python turtle module
and you see i'm using duckduckgo so
yeah so control fine and fill
aha so it's begin fill
and end fill okay so
control fine begin fill
okay so i think how this works let's try
this i'm kind of curious
um so i did it once before but it's been
a while
um pen go to angular okay
so pen dot begin fill
pen dot enfill
and i think what that will do let's see
if it works
fudge ah it's underscore
let's try that again yes
so what it did was it filled in
that area so as you begin fill you draw
an enclosed shape and then it fills it
in for you that's pretty cool i'm pretty
happy with that
so what i want to do is
i'm going to change the color
so instead of white i'm going to make
the cards blue
okay and then what i'm going to do with
the
suits and everything is i'm going to
draw that in white for now so pen dot
color
white let's see what that does what i
want it to do
oh my gosh that looks cool hey there's
my playing cards that is pretty pretty
cool
so i i can live with that i'm i'm pretty
happy with that um
these spades cool now the other thing i
might want to do
uh the color instead of white
um for the symbols
if it's spades or clubs i could make
well
i'm gonna leave it white for now i'm
gonna get a little tired at this point
sorry so we can probably figure it out i
guess if you want to change the colors
so just a quick rehash of what we've
done here
is we've created a simple turtle window
a turtle pen
a card class it has name suit and a list
of symbols
so we can convert you know the d to a
diamond the c
to a club an h to hearts s s2
spades okay and then we have a print
card so if we wanted to print that
out down here we could do that but what
we really want to do was to render it
and you can see i just kind of played
around with the numbers until i got it
you know looking how i wanted to i use
the begin fill and end fill
to create a you know a closed
area that's filled in and again you can
play around with the colors and things
and i just used you know the penrite
method and
go to some very simple stuff and again i
just kind of played around with the
numbers
again if you have a different font or a
different computer you'll probably play
around the numbers a little bit
to get things where you want them to be
for your your machine
now of course you could use a pre-made
image
actually now i look at that little bit
yeah it's a little bit extra space so
i'm going to move that down just a
little bit
so i'm going to make that 60 let me make
that one
75. now the advantage of doing it the
way i'm doing it
is the fact that you don't have to have
any external images
you can see everything's being done with
this one file
and so that's that now
that was one card okay so
here's what we want to do is now we want
to create an entire deck
of cards
now if you again at this point i guess
you could just stop and say okay well
i see what i have seen um i've done what
i've done
um this this is actually probably a
really good place
to stop because you have you can draw
basically any arbitrary card
so i can make ace of spades let's say
king of
diamonds i should probably test it and
let's see here and you see we got a king
of diamonds now maybe i don't need the
diamond because
you know we got a diamond here i don't
know if that's that's overkill
but you can design your card however you
like it
so what i'd probably do at this point is
go ahead and start making a deck okay
so now i'm going to make a new class
called deck
and i'm going to initialize it
and see here
self
and i'm gonna create a a deck a deck is
made up of
cards so cards so i make a list of cards
and what i'm gonna say is uh let's see
here
cards okay so
so we've got names and the names the
cards
are right because this would be a tuple
ace king queen
jack ten
nine eight
seven six oops
six five four
three two oops two
and there's no one so aces can have a
value of one or eleven blackjack
depending on the game
and then the suits is gonna equal
fudge we've got
what was it diamonds i like to keep
things in the same order
diamonds clubs heart spades so diamonds
clubs hearts and spades
so what i'm going to do is the following
so for name and names
for suit in suits
it doesn't matter which order you do it
in but since that's the way i did it
we'll do it that way
i'm going to create a new card
and so we name and suit
and then i'm going to append that card
to the cards
now what i'm going to do now is i'm
going to go ahead and create a deck so
say deck
equals deck
okay and i want to try this i'm going to
say for card in deck
dot cards card
dot print
card and what that should do
is give us a printed list of all the
cards
and instead it gave us an error
so ah duh this should be self.card sorry
about that
so hopefully somebody figured that out
um
self.cards now this names and suits is
not
self because i don't need access to
these outside of
that okay
so let's go ahead and there we go
so you can see how it works
so ace of diamonds clubs hearts spades
king of diamonds clubs hearts spades etc
etc
and i've got all of my cards
okay now at this point
you know i can kind of play around with
it a little bit uh let's see here
let's go ahead and see what we got here
so again we want to try and render all
these cards let's go ahead and just do
i'm going to
do a card dot render and i'm going to
render them all
at 0 0 and using that pen
now i'm going to go back up here and get
rid of
pen speed because i want it to be slow
so let's see what happens here
so what it's doing is it's rendering all
of those
in order on top of
oh you see the queen kind of overwrites
that because the queue is a big letter
oh you can see how the 10 is now outside
of that so we got it we got to deal with
that
okay so this is good this is kind of
giving us an idea now also you can see
how this is still back here
okay so what we're going to want to do
probably is um
okay think about that
see what happens if i do this i'm kind
of curious
okay so it's clearing drawing clearing
drawing it's a little bit slow but
we can speed it up with uh speed um so
one of the things we had to fix was that
the queue has that little hanging part
down so what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to move
this down just a little bit so i'm going
to make that 25
and that means i need to move this up
just a little bit
uh and i need to move this down just a
little bit so that should be 80.
so that should fix the queen problem so
i'm going to go back to
get rid of this clear
okay ace works hearts works ace is good
kings are good
um kings kings and queens okay queens
are fine now
okay but we solve the problem with ten
because ten is two characters wide as
opposed to one character
so we have a choice here um what we
could do
is we could just you know make a special
case
um in our rendering if you know if the
name is 10 and then we change the x
location a little bit is one option
or what we could do is change this to a
t
that's kind of a lazy person's way of
doing it
and i am nothing if not a lazy person
sometimes so
i'm gonna leave i think i'm gonna go
with the t thing you can play around
with the
10 thing if you'd like um
yeah pretty happy with this not bad for
for a quick video so that was 33 minutes
now there's a couple there's a t yeah so
i think i'm okay with that um again
you'd probably want to change that to a
10 just to
you know make it look better but um i'm
gonna live with that for now
so thinking about a deck
um of course we don't want the deck to
always be in that
same order so i'm gonna go ahead and go
back to card.print
card
and then i'm going to go ahead and make
a new method
so it's going to be called shuffle
self and so what i'm going to do is
ah okay now i haven't done this for a
while so i think i got to use the
input the random module so import random
and then what i'm going to do here is
uh random dot
shuffle uh cards
self die cards and this is a
this is a method of the random module
and it takes a list which we created we
created a list of cards here
and it just shuffles them in a random
order so let's go ahead and run it
and okay now notice nothing happened
because i forgot to shuffle
so deck dot shuffle
so i gotta shuffle the deck let's try
that and there you go you can see now we
have a bunch of random
in a random order let's go ahead and run
it again to see if it comes out
differently this time
and i think it did so there is our deck
um pretty cool actually um
but what we want to do now so then
instead of printing that
is we need to pull cards off of the deck
okay so
well do we for this are we just
rendering i guess i guess
um what can we do here so
basically at this point we don't really
need to worry so much about the card
class
that's why i use classes okay i'm done
with that so
i'm going to say def what can we do all
this choose card
self and
choose card get card i'll call it get
card
and i'm gonna go ahead and do the
following
card equals self dot cards
dot pop
and i'm going to say return
card
okay so i'm gonna shuffle it and i'm
gonna say
card equals deck
dot get card
i'm gonna say card dot render
so what this will do is it will
pop a card off of the deck
return it to me and then i can render it
so i'm gonna go ahead and do that
okay duh i gotta render it somewhere
and i use the pen
okay so it gave me the queen of diamonds
okay that's pretty cool i guess
what i want to try let's let's try this
here
let's see if it works so i'm going to
say
for blank in range let's say we'll just
pull off ten cards
okay and then time dot sleep
five seconds and then we'll say pen dot
clear we'll clear the pen so pen.clear
just erases whatever the pen has done
okay so what we're going to do is we're
going to create a deck
so i'll put this up without a comment
here create deck
deck shuffle the deck
okay and then we're gonna go ahead and
render
ten cards in our row
okay so hopefully this will do what we
wanted to do okay so we've got five of
clubs
eight of clubs
seven of diamonds
three of clubs
six of diamonds i'm pretty happy it's
it's it's working at least
it's doing what i wanted it to do so let
me go ahead and try that one more time
just to make sure we got a different
set of set of uh cards here so seven of
diamonds
queen of hearts yeah so clearly as far
as i can tell it's working
exactly as we wanted it to and now you
know what i could do at this point
you know what i might want to do is you
know
get five cards and then we'll say like
start
x uh say start x
equals let's see if five cards 50 75
that's two i don't know we'll say minus
150
plus 125 so 175.
then we'll do is we'll say
i'm going to do i though i guess maybe x
i don't know
so we'll go x say start x
plus i times and the width of each card
is what a hundred was it
gonna go back up to the render thing
here
uh go to negative 50. yeah so cards are
100 wide
so let's see 150 300
75 let's see minus i'll try minus 300.
um l250
and then times 125.
and i don't think we need that anymore
so what this should do is draw five
cards on the screen uh
i think i is not defined because it's
gonna be
x the
two three four and five that looks
pretty centered to me
so there is our deck of cards
simulator okay yeah i know that
didn't do quite a super explanation here
but i think you can go back and kind of
figure out what's going on here
now notice when i get a card i don't
know if i didn't really mention this
but when i get the card it is now gone
from the deck
okay so that deck does not have that
card
anymore so it is it is no longer there
so
probably what you want to do is to
create a function
so def uh you know
reset you know reset deck or something
like that
and then probably what i would do is i
would just copy this
and just pop that in there and then what
that'll let you do
is you know let's say you're playing a
card game
and then you give out some cards to some
players okay games
you know that that round is over then
you just basically reset the deck
and shuffle it don't forget to shuffle
it um
and that will put it back to its normal
order now you could you could go ahead
and put shuffle in here you say
self.shuffle
so it automatically shuffles itself
after you reset it so
let's try that let's go ahead and see if
this is working
so instead of shuffling deck i'm just
going to say reset
and i and the reason it's separate is
you know let's say you take out a couple
cards then you want to shuffle them for
some reason
okay so you have two separate functions
to do that
let's try that again dec
object has no function reset reset deck
i'm going to change that to reset
because i don't um that it's redundant
and
it is working as expected okay
you can see how it's rendering slowly
the only reason it's doing that is
because i
i made it do that um so because i wanted
to be able to see what was going on so
if i put pen speed to zero
and then it just they just popped right
up um you did see them pop but
that was kind of cool actually the way
that worked and then maybe
maybe you might want to add one more
uh card i'm not sure about this
so you might want to make a card let me
think about this
okay so something like this so
if the self.suit
uh does not equal quote
or self. we'll say self.name
i'll show you why i'm doing this in a
second
okay so what you can do
in let's see how do i do that
so what i'm trying to do is try to
figure out you know how to draw it face
down
so what you could do is just create a
card
so let's see so for example
i know i'll do okay
so i'm gonna take this
and double it and
instead of taking the card from the deck
i'm gonna say card
and it's gonna be no name and no suit
and i'm gonna say time dot sleep
uh five seconds okay and hopefully this
will do what i want to do yeah there we
go
so there is an empty card and then after
five seconds
boom it prints the cards so
yeah that's that's a way to do it um
and then we were done we would clear the
screen i'm really happy with that that's
pretty cool
um anyway so there is your deck of cards
simulator uh now i'm pretty happy with
this this is this is pretty cool this
turned out way better i thought it was
going to
but you see you know basically what i
did one more time
so the card itself you know has a name
and a suit
and again i chose to use d
c h and s and i also chose to use t
instead of 10 because of the rendering
now you could fix that if you wanted to
and then but when i do render it i want
to have the diamonds i want to have the
club i want to have the spa
or the heart and the spade symbol
instead so i have a print card method
if i want to make a text based game but
i also have this render method that
works with
a turtle pen so i can render it anywhere
on the screen
and then if the card says self name is
empty is not empty because we use that
to represent
the back of a card now i could make a
method you know render
you know render back of card or
something like that uh
if if i wanted to i don't have to do it
the way i'm doing it
it's just a way of doing it now
then i have a deck and it's got it's
basically made up of cards
and we have all the different names we
have all the different suits
and we do a little nested loop here
create the cards
append them to the list
we can shuffle using the random shuffle
method we can get a card
and again pop removes
an item from a list i forget if it's the
first item or the last item probably the
first item
and but i could be wrong on that but
once you shuffle it doesn't matter if
it's coming from
the the end or the beginning and then we
also need to be able to reset
and in the reset we decided to shuffle
so we just created all these cards over
again
you know delete the old list and then
recreated it
and then we created a deck so deck is
deck
and then we reset the deck which
shuffles it
and then uh so basically when we do this
we could then
yeah well i guess that gives you a deck
in in order so maybe there's a reason
so then basically what i did was i
rendered five cards in a row
uh five cards i'll put that in the back
in a row and so i just started at
negative 250 then jumped 125 each time
and it worked out and i got lucky with
the uh
the the center it looks really cool
actually it rendered each card
slept for five seconds and then dealt
five
cards from the deck and that's my
friends
is that thanks for watching
uh click like subscribe leave a leave a
comment and if you're able to
please join as a member and get early
access to stuff like this
take care and keep on coding